merci
merci Monsieur Miss d'avoir bien voulu
accepter notre invitation à l'issue de
ces
QG pour échanger avec les membres de la
mission d'information sur la gestion
durable de l'eau
nous travaillons depuis le mois de
février
et nous deux nous allons rendre notre
rapport donc le 11 juillet prochain
cette mission a été lancée au Sénat en
février à la demande du groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains et
tous les groupes politiques y sont
représentés afin de garantir évidemment
une approche
transpartizane du sujet comme on le fait
habituellement au Sénat
l'enjeu n'est pas seulement de réfléchir
à la gestion des crises celle-ci étant
de plus en plus nombreuse et fréquentes
comme on l'a vu en 2022 puis cette année
2023 même si on a quelques épisodes de
pluvieux les nappes sont toujours pas
remontés au niveau
nous nous mobilisons pour analyser
l'architecture générale de la politique
de l'eau en France
ces aspects quantitatifs et qualitatifs
et puis les menaces à long terme que
fait peser le changement climatique et
envisager des solutions pour éviter
d'être pris de court
le président de la République annoncé il
y a deux mois un plan o avec 53 mesures
qui promulent la sobriété
prévoit des dispositions financières
et un renforcement de la gouvernance de
l'eau
ce plan a été globalement bien accueilli
par les acteurs et les experts du
domaine
même si certains trouvent que il est
trop faible en sur le plan financier
il reste à passer maintenant à la phase
de mise en œuvre
et nous avons voulu vous entendre avant
de terminer nos travaux pour échanger
sur le plan o sa déclinaison mais aussi
sur l'opportunité de construire de
nouvelles retenues à usage agricole ou
encore de mieux protéger la ressource de
nouveaux polluants
alors nos échanges pourraient se
dérouler de la manière suivante si vous
le permettez
nous vous laissons un temps de
présentation générale de 10 à 15 minutes
puis ensuite nous passerons aux
questions des membres de la mission mais
avant de vous laisser la parole monsieur
le ministre je vais la donner à notre
apporteur de la mission notre collègue
sénateur de la Gironde Hervé Gillet
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre présence
et votre disponibilité que nous
apprécions à l'issue effectivement de
nos travaux nous souhaitions donc avoir
ce temps d'échange
puisque comme l'indiqué Rémi nous allons
rendre ce rapport dans les prochains
jours donc le plan haut fixe une feuille
de route pour aller vers plus de
sobriété moins de conflictualité dans la
gestion de l'eau et nous sommes allés
sur le terrain et nous avons pu vérifier
qu'effectivement certaines situations
méritaient une attention particulière
alors ce sujet jusqu'à maintenant était
un sujet parfois d'initié il restait
dans un Sénacle particulier mais
aujourd'hui loi jaillit au centre des
controverses depuis quelques mois et a
donc renforcé son ancrage politique à
cette tant mieux mais avec la crainte de
ne pas avoir suffisamment pris la mesure
des bouleversements qui nous attendent
et sur lesquels vous êtes régulièrement
intervenu les conflits liés à l'eau se
multiplient les craintes de pénurie se
concrétisent dans certains territoires
avec des mesures de restriction qui
deviennent de quasi permanente avec la
sécheresse hivernale que nous avons pu
connaître alors que faire comment agir
le rapport sur le retour d'expérience de
la sécheresse 2022 recommande davantage
anticiper de donner un cadre d'action
plus homogène au préfet et service de
l'État mais tout en permettant quand
même une différenciation territoriale
qui est nécessaire il a donc abouti à
l'édition d'un nouveau guide nous
l'avons étudié avec précision une
politique de l'eau durable est
résiliente ne se résume pas à la gestion
de crise nous le savons il faut aussi
des réponses donc structurelles alors
nous nous attendons que vous ne
reprécisiez les mesures que vous
envisagez pour mieux retourner l'eau
naturellement dans nos sols et dans nos
sous-sols première préoccupation faut-il
davantage protéger les zones humides et
notre rapport fera sans doute des
préconisations notamment en termes de
documents d'urbanisme sur le sujet à
quelles conditions peut-on retenir l'eau
quand elle est abondante pour mieux
l'utiliser derrière ces questions il y a
celle des retenues à usage agricole mais
aussi la relance éventuelle d'une
politique de retenue multi-usage
puisqu'on voit bien que cette approche
est absolument essentielle aujourd'hui
comment faire face aux nouveaux
polluants et aux polluants anciens mais
persistant dans l'environnement doit-on
aller vers un renforcement des normes de
rejet voire des interdictions et du coup
ça réinterroge le nombre de zones de
captage prioritaire aujourd'hui et qu'il
faudra nécessairement élargir et qui
pose la question des services rendus
environnementaux comment améliorer des
services d'eau et d'assainissement
n'a-t-on pas trop réduit les aides
financières dont peuvent bénéficier des
collectivités gestionnaires de ces
services pour lutter contre les fuites
ou mettre aux normes les stations
d'épuration le plan au fait des
propositions mais partiales partielles
pour l'instant donc il faut regarder
peut-être comment avancer d'une manière
plus significative le chantier de la
tarification progressive la tarification
sociale de l'eau vous l'avez posée
également au niveau du plan haut avec
des travaux qui pourraient être confiés
aux saisies et au Parlement pour avancer
sur ces sujets là et on voit bien
l'intérêt d'avoir aussi un groupe de
travail national pour avancer ensemble
car le sujet est complexe et normatif et
législatif vraisemblablement l'absence
de visibilité sur les concessions
hydrolactiques peut nuire également la
bonne gestion multi-usages des retenues
de montagnes notamment et sur certains
bassins c'est une question importante
notamment celui qui me concerne
particulièrement à Dour Garonne et enfin
les ptge semblent constituer
l'instrument privilégié de concertation
sur les territoires nous partageons bien
sûr cette cette vision et d'où satisfait
aujourd'hui de l'avancement quelle
expérience vous retirez nous voyons bien
quand les ptge sont pas bien plantés ou
implantés au démarrage qui ne risquent
pas les conditions en amont bien souvent
il pose un certain nombre de questions
mais d'ores et déjà il y a donc des
situations et des retours d'expérience
qui doivent alimenter les réflexions que
vous avez pu avoir au niveau du plan
haut
et je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté et
je vous laisse donc vous exprimer comme
le Président vous en a fait la
proposition monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président pointe trop
monsieur rapporteur gilet mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
j'ai bien envie de sauter l'introduction
vu le nombre de questions que vous
m'avez déjà posées et le fait que
j'avais cru comprendre que ce serait un
échange court et qui se concentrerait
sur un certain nombre de points si je
pars sur l'intro je vais où épuiser une
partie des questions que vous me posez
ou tapez à côté en vous racontant des
choses que vous savez déjà et qui n'ont
pas un intérêt immense pour la mission
d'information je vais donc peut-être
juste me contenter d'expliquer d'où
vient le plan o en deux minutes pour
respecter formellement l'exercice et
puis après on ira sur tous les sujets et
ils sont nombreux et ils n'ont pas tous
été épuisés par la présentation et de ce
point de vue vos questions sont
pertinents et je considère que cette
audition elle peut être une façon
d'aller compléter ce qui a été présenté
le 30 mars
il n'y a pas rien eu avant il y a eu le
Varenne de l'eau il y a eu des assises
mais si on se dit les choses on a fait
entrer dans l'atmosphère cette question
de l'eau mais on n'a pas été au bout de
la logique et on a annoncé des principes
sans entrer sur les modalités qui
permettraient de les tenir
le plus important c'est qu'on a par
exemple dit qu'il faudrait qu'on fasse
preuve de sobriété mais au lieu d'en
faire un objectif territorialisé et de
commencer à poser la question des moyens
sur comment on faisait on est resté sur
des orientations plus qu'on est d'ores
et déjà entré dans le détail
et l'année 2022 elle a joué je pense un
rôle de révélateur à bien des égards
elle vient pas de nulle part nous avons
connu dans cette année là un mois de
juillet qui a été déficitaire à hauteur
de 88%
le plus sec jamais enregistré qui est
venu accentuer des déficits d'eau qui
était pas hyper visible au début de
l'année 2022
mais qui du coup ce sont traduits par
cette situation unique 93 départements
dans lesquels il y a eu des arrêtés qui
ont été pris et 75 dans lesquels à la
fin seul l'eau potable les est autorisée
les chiffres dont on n'avait pas
l'habitude plus de 700 communes privées
d'eau potable
à un moment ou un autre et dans ce
chiffre des 700 un peu moins de 400 qui
ont été ravitaillés par citerne et près
de 180 qui l'ont été par bouteille
ces éléments là
conjugués au fait que nous avons des
statistiques persistantes qui ne sont
pas glorieuses avec seulement 44% des
masses d'eau qui sont en bon état
écologique
montre que sur la quantité on a un sujet
et sur la qualité on a un sujet
dès la fin de l'été on a à la fois lancé
un travail avec tout le monde sous
l'égide du Conseil national de l'eau en
travaillant beaucoup avec les comités de
bassins et vous avez bien voulu monsieur
le Président pointeau dire que le
rapport avait été cueilli favorablement
il a été accueilli favorablement par
ceux qui en grande partie avec contribué
à l'écrire
mes services moi même on a été j'allais
dire les synthétiseurs des remarques et
ceux qui ont obtenu les arbitrages qui
nous ont permis de faire en sorte qui
est 53 mesures à la fin qui permettent
d'adresser à peu près tous ces
différents éléments avec trois grands
objectifs dire qu'il n'y a pas
d'alternative à une forme de sobriété et
qui a forcément des usages qui faut être
capable de bouger de qu'on a une telle
culture de l'abondance que nous
gaspillons une eau qui est autour de
nous et dont nous devrions optimiser
l'utilisation c'est les eaux usées c'est
l'eau grise c'est la lutte contre les
fuites 3 regarder en face le problème de
la qualité ça n'est pas normal qu'on est
autant de secteurs dans lequel nous
n'ayons pas de plan de gestion
pour prendre un exemple sur les captages
etc et il nous faut des mesures et des
mesures qui permettent d'aller
accompagner des agriculteurs et 4 quel
budget quel gouvernance et sortons de
l'infantilisation vis-à-vis des agences
qui consistent en gros à ce qu'on est
des plafonds mordants pour les dépenses
des plafonds pour les recettes une
difficulté à agir alors qu'on prétend
qu'il s'agit d'un sujet de compétence
locale tout à la fin le 30 mars un
assouplissement sur les modes de gestion
pour que l'intercommunalité ne soit pas
le seul et unique horizon de la gestion
mais qu'on puisse tenir compte de
réalité topographique et vous avez le
plan
et maintenant toutes les questions que
vous posez qui sont légitimes et
auxquelles je préfère répondre de
manière plus directe quand vous lisant
des fiches qui reprennent quelques
éléments sur la genèse et surtout ça
si ça vous convient
alors
est-ce que tu penses que quelques
questions après nos collègues poseront
une série de questions
donc une série de questions monsieur
ministre répond et puis ensuite on
passera la parole aussi à nos collègues
très bien alors on va aller un peu plus
dans le détail et sur des questions qui
ont remonté aussi au travers donc de nos
auditions et de nos visites de terrain
vous abordiez justement la question de
la sobriété donc l'objectif des 10% qui
a été donc indiqué dans le cadre du Plan
haut est-ce que vous pouvez nous
repréciser au niveau du secteur agricole
globalement quelles sont vos objectifs
parce que on sent quand même qu'il y a
un positionnement parfois différencié et
que le ministre de l'Agriculture donc on
a on aurait besoin quand même d'une
clarification sur sur ces sujets là
nous vous parlions également au niveau
des zones humides et le fait d'améliorer
la qualité des sols et de voir de quelle
manière cette permabalisation des sols
peut s'inscrire d'une manière durable
alors bien sûr c'est au travers des
pratiques mais derrière les pratiques il
y aura peut-être aussi des évolutions à
négocier dans le cadre de la PAC mais il
y a des pistes de travail qui émergent
aujourd'hui qui était pas forcément
reprise d'une manière forte dans les
propositions que vous avez pu faire sur
l'inscription dans les documents
d'urbanisme d'une manière plus
stratégique la gestion de l'eau et
notamment la gestion du pluvial qui
souvent n'est pas géré d'une manière
très stratégique dans les territoires
qu'en pensez-vous quel type de
proposition éventuellement vous pourriez
faire ou est-ce que vous nous
accompariez justement sur le
renforcement qu'on pourrait prévoir dans
les documents d'urbanisme aujourd'hui
un chantier qui est important et qui a
été placé qui a été mis sur la table
suite à votre volonté c'est bien sûr la
révision des redevances aujourd'hui
donc il y a eu des travaux où en sont
donc ces travaux est-ce que vous êtes
déjà en situation d'arbitrage par
rapport à ces sujets qui sont des sujets
fondamentaux aujourd'hui pour
accompagner la politique des moyens et
surtout voir derrière cette politique
des moyens seulement elle va être mise
en oeuvre au niveau de l'échéancier par
rapport aux nouveaux plans des agences
qui étaient qui sont prévues donc en
2024 et ce qu'on sera au rendez-vous
pour pouvoir accompagner les mesures les
plus fortes notamment au niveau d'autres
plans donc je m'arrêterai tout d'abord
sur ces ministres
très bien il y a pas d'agriculture sans
eau et il faut le dire avec beaucoup de
force
il faut arrêter de penser qu'un usage
agricole est un incapable
personne ne conteste le fait qu'on a
besoin d'eau pour boire personne ne
devrait contester qu'on a besoin d'eau
pour se nourrir et donc il faut faire en
sorte de pas avoir des usages qui
génèrent un gaspillage mais on peut pas
incriminer avoir une vision qui soit
trop basique sur ces sujets quand j'ai
dit ça j'ai presque résumé ce qui est
censé être le chemin de crête et donc je
vais prendre un tout petit pas de côté
ça me resservira peut-être un peu plus
tard quand on discutera des retenues si
vous l'évoquez pour savoir si c'est la
solution ou une des solutions
en gros ce que disent les experts et
c'est l'avantage d'avoir découvert le
sujet c'est que j'ai été obligé de poser
des questions bêtes qui me permettent
parfois de d'expliquer les choses à
d'autres qui les connaissent mieux que
moi mais qui au moins me permettent de
le faire d'une manière simple on a 500
milliards de mètres cubes d'eau qui ne
tombent sur la tête en France et on en
aura a priori à peu près autant dans les
années qui viennent la seule chose c'est
que là où aujourd'hui quand la partie
qui part dans les vapo transpiration ok
absorbé par les plantes nous en les 160
qui sont disponibles
je ne me battrai pas avec le président
pointe trop sur ce sujet je mesure déjà
l'imprudence qui est la mienne d'aller
sur le thème mettons entre 160 et 200 on
en a à la fin 33 qu'on prélève et 5
qu'on consomme le problème c'est que
c'est ce 160 ou ce 200 qui va baisser
parce qu'avec l'augmentation moyenne de
la température une part n'arrivera plus
dans nos cours d'eau une part trouvera
une végétation qu'aura davantage poussée
et fera en sorte qu'on a moins donc ça
n'est pas un problème d'alternance
politique ou de couleur politique du
gouvernement de considérer qu'on aura
moins d'eau au préalable et cette
réalité elle vaudra pour tous les
acteurs y compris pour les agriculteurs
quand j'ai posé ce contexte il n'y a
donc aucun modèle dans lequel à la fin
il n'y a pas à tout le monde une
sobriété à l'hectare
on peut discuter de la part donc on
réserve à l'agriculture au globale mais
il y a pas de schéma sur le fait que
nous ne pourrons pas conserver le même
niveau sans sobriété sur les différents
territoires on a des réserves
fantastiques sans mauvais jeu de mots 8%
seulement de nos espaces agricoles sont
irrités en goutte à coude pour ce qu'ils
sont et de manière plus large
il va de soi que l'augmentation des
températures indépendamment de toute loi
elle provoquera des évolutions sur les
pratiques j'attends les chiffres mais
pour avoir discuté avec le président de
l'association des chambres d'agriculture
il me dit qu'il y a déjà depuis l'été
2022 des milliers d'exploitations qui
ont fait évoluer leur pratique en
anticipant le fait que Ré à nouveau des
difficultés donc dans ce schéma global
on voit bien que on a besoin de toute
façon de regarder comment on est capable
de tenir mieux compte et des sols et du
climat par rapport à ce que nous faisons
pousser et d'autre part de faire évoluer
nos modèles vers plus de sobriété à
l'hectare
faisons attention à éviter les
raccourcis
ce ne sont on se focalise sur les
cultures qui sont gourmandes en eau
l'été puisque c'est le moment où on a la
conflictualité sur les usages mais ce
sont pas nécessairement ce que nous
faisons pousser l'été qui consomment le
plus d'eau on a des cultures divers
mais dans des moments pour le moment les
plus sont abondantes qui n'engendrent
pas de difficultés si on devrait avoir
des sécheresses hivernales à répétition
des difficultés de ce type le regard
comporterait y compris sur certains
types de culture pour ne plus être le
même d'autre part cette eau elle ne
profite pas seulement à ce qui se
produit elle profite à la biodiversité
parce que quand vous arrivez des espaces
pendant l'été vous ne permettez pas
seulement aux cultures de poussée vous
permettez à la vie abrité par ses
cultures de pouvoir elle-même se
poursuivre un titre ou un autre donc il
faut qu'on donne un chemin qui sécurise
l'agriculture parce que c'est ce qui
permet de nous nourrir ce chemin passe
nécessairement par de la sobriété mais
il passe aussi par des investissements
et dans ces investissements il y a ce
goutte-à-goutte où il y a le suivi de ce
qui peut être approprié je propose de
pas aller beaucoup plus loin à ce stade
je peux rentrer dans le détail une
partie du plan prévoit des dispositifs
de soutien notamment à ce type de
pratique et d'évolution
vous avez évoqué la question des
captages
parce que tout est lié
dans les usages agricoles sur la qualité
des eaux moins d'eau en moyenne dans les
cours d'eau avec un niveau de résidu
constant ça voudra dire sans aucune
évolution de la législation
des remontées de taux par rapport à
l'eau disponible qui engendreront des
fermetures de captage à droit constant
donc dans ce domaine et ça n'est pas une
prédiction c'est une anticipation qui me
semble
assez inéluctable
notre engagement c'est celui de doter
chaque plan de captage de ce qu'on
appelle un pgse qui permet précisément
au préfet de pouvoir déterminer le seuil
à part de déclenchement à partir duquel
nous faisons en sorte
d'éviter de continuer à les capter là où
il y aurait un risque d'eslables pour la
santé humaine et ça renvoie une autre
question c'est comment on évite d'avoir
trop de services d'eau qui ne dépendent
que d'un seul d'un point de captage ce
qui est peut-être une façon moins
polémique de poser la question de est-ce
qu'une commune isolée a le droit de
gérer son système d'eau toute seule mais
à la fin ça revient à ça que ce soit
pour la disponibilité en eau potable
pour la qualité on n'a pas intérêt à
avoir des services qui ne dépendent que
d'un seul point de captage parce que ça
entraîne un niveau de fragilité qui est
l'inverse de tous les dispositifs de
sécurisation ou d'interconnexion que
nous poussons
je n'arrive pas à me relire si plus Vial
pardon c'est le deuxième mot que j'ai
écrit puisque je crois que c'est là
dessus que vous m'avez interrogé
tout est lié il n'y a pas de meilleur
retenu il n'y a pas de meilleur bassine
que dans la pratique
et donc dit autrement
la volonté exprimée ici par le Sénat de
dire qu'il fallait répartir différemment
la consommation foncière dans le cadre
du zan mais ne pas remettre en cause
l'objectif il est une contribution à la
restauration d'un grand cycle de l'eau
qui soit vertueux lutter contre
l'artificialisation c'est préserver la
capacité de notaire de pouvoir jouer ce
rôle d'éponge de pouvoir stocker dans
nos nappes phréatiques de l'eau dont
ensuite on a besoin qui ne s'évapore pas
avec les mêmes coefficients que si ça se
fait en surface et qui nous permet donc
de lutter contre ça le début d'une
politique fluviale ambitieuse c'est
celle qui consiste à se préoccuper de la
limitation de l'artificialisation qui
accélère les écoulements et qui bouge
les nappes
après à la différence de d'autres
politiques du cycle de l'eau
reconnaissons que ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui sur les eaux pluviales que
notre pays est le mieux armé
la culture de l'abondance dont je
parlais elle nous a conduit à écarter
les usages de l'eau pluviale pour un
certain d'usage domestique et quand je
parlais rapidement
des sources d'optimisation
très clairement il y a la question de la
réutilisation des eaux usées sur lequel
je vais pas revenir et qui je pense fait
une partie de l'unanimité avec une
subtilité c'est qu'elle est
particulièrement efficace en littorale
si ça consiste à ne pas la rejeter dans
la mer à l'intérieur des terres une
partie de ces Eaux-Vives on est content
de les rejeter dans le milieu parce
qu'elle servent à d'autres usages tout
au long ensuite des cours d'eau en
revanche à l'intérieur des terres
le fait d'aller regarder comment de
l'eau de pluie peut alimenter des
toilettes
pour éviter que ce soit de l'eau potable
ou comment des eaux grises qui sont
issus des machines peuvent elles aussi
assurer ce rôle ça semble être assez
logique y compris pour l'énergie qu'on
économise ça évite de la potabiliser sur
l'économie de ressources tout court que
ça génère et sur le fait que ça
s'inscrit dans un cycle qui ne change
rien au fait qu'ensuite elle passera
dans d'autres donc on a des axes évident
d'amélioration ce plan ce sera pas le
dernier sur l'eau il est sans doute par
son ampleur
il fait date par rapport à aux décisions
précédentes qui avaient pu être prise et
par le fait que il essaye de s'adresser
à la totalité ou à beaucoup de secteurs
mais ça fait partie des volets sur
lesquels nous aurons sans doute des axes
encore sur lesquels les choses devront
être améliorées et la généralisation des
gemapi était là aussi récente on est
dans une prise de compétences des
collectivités mais qui va nécessiter de
continuer à s'affiner au fur et à mesure
du temps
sur la redevance on a un avis du Conseil
National de l'Eau me semble-t-il du 5
mai qui propose de faire évoluer les
dispositifs je parle sur votre contrôle
et je vois toujours sous votre contrôle
la semaine prochaine tous les présidents
de comité de bassin
donc vous êtes quelques jours avant que
je partage avec eux ce que pourrait être
les évolutions telles qu'on les envisage
et qu'on les mette en œuvre
bien sûr je n'ai aucun doute je sais à
quel point un secret partagé par plus de
personnes est déjà naturellement un
secret et je sais à quel point cette
audition qui ne débouchera sur aucun
rapport public restera complètement
entre nous
je me propose si vous en êtes d'accord
peut-être de vous faire passer une
contribution écrite
qui serait postérieure à ma rencontre
avec les présidents de comité de bassin
pour que vous fassiez pas l'impasse sur
le sujet
mais qui me permettent de ne pas me
placer dans une situation où ils
entreraient dans la salle en ayant le
sentiment que je vous ai partagé des
décisions qui seraient prises par
rapport à des recommandations qui m'ont
été faites si ça vous convient vous
connaissez les grandes lignes de toute
façon si on est honnête de ce qui est
envisager vous avez une idée de ce que
sont les montants et la volonté que dès
le PLF 2024 donc dans quelques mois nous
puissions commencer à débattre de cette
question
merci
à mes collègues qui souhaitent poser des
questions
genre
le ministre je pense que
on ne fait pas de petites économies
tout est bon à prendre aujourd'hui on
sait que la forêt participe grandement à
la qualité des eaux mais aussi que les
arbres pompent énormément et
évaporent cette eau
il y a sur Grimaud une société la
Société des Eaux atmosphériques qui
aujourd'hui a mis en place un process
qui permet à partir de cette humidité
qui est dans l'air de récupérer de l'eau
de l'eau qui aujourd'hui est brute ils
sont en train de finir les analyses pour
démontrer qu'elle est potable
donc ça peut être un secours pour les
communes qui aujourd'hui sont en manque
d'eau et sont alimentés par par des
bouteilles d'eau donc un système comme
ça c'est un
ça peut se développer sous plusieurs
formes aujourd'hui leur modèle c'est
un caisson qui produit 5000 litres jours
mais bon ils peuvent l'augmenter et ils
ont un projet de capacité
d'embouteillages d'eau de 50 000
bouteilles jours donc la possibilité de
produire pas mal d'eau voilà une
solution je sais pas si vous la
connaissiez donc à la limite voilà
et puis une question qui
enfin notre depuis longtemps
quand on produit des énergies
renouvelables que ce soit de l'éolien ou
du photovoltaïque on produit pas
toujours
cette énergie au moment où on a besoin
de la consommer
dans certains secteurs c'est peut-être
pas généralisable mais dans cet acte
secteur comme le verre d'eau où il y a
une succession de barrages il y a 5
barrages successifs il est possible et
les barrages certains sont équipés avec
une turbine inverse de remonter l'eau
dans le barrage
l'idée serait que au moment où on
produit cette électricité qui n'est pas
nécessairement consommée
l'envoyer au barrage pour remonter de
l'eau de façon à ce que le barrage
reproduise l'électricité avec cette eau
au moment où on en a besoin aujourd'hui
techniquement c'est tout à fait faisable
réglementairement ça n'est pas parce que
la creux a pas défini les critères qui
convenaient pour pouvoir qu'on puisse le
faire
alors
j'ai eu entre les mains les plaquettes
de société faisant effectivement de
l'eau potable à partir de condensation
avec plusieurs types de volume avec le
fait que c'est des gens c'est déjà
déployé dans certains pays en
particulier plutôt en Afrique à la
minute où nous parlons
et avec une étude scientifique dont je
me souviens vaguement de la lecture il y
a quelques semaines mais qui disait
qu'en gros pour chaque degré de
température supplémentaire le lot
disponible augmenter de 7% par degré
dans l'air en termes de concentration
les chiffres sont à vérifier mais je
crois ne pas me tromper par rapport à ce
cette publication que j'avais lu
la vraie difficulté c'est très
énergivore et donc l'énergie qu'il faut
pour être capable de produire une
quantité d'eau de ce type et
particulièrement important
et donc si on se dit les choses je suis
très intéressé parce que ça pourrait
typiquement être une bonne installation
de secours pour des lieux qui se
retrouveraient privés d'eau potable dans
des circonstances estivales mais c'est
pas là dessus qu'on peut faire évoluer
notre modèle hors crise
en tout cas à ce stade de la même
manière que je serai extrêmement prudent
sur les usines de dessalement d'eau de
mer ou de désalinisation qui elle aussi
ont un problème de coût énergétique
important et qui si elles sont mal
réglées peuvent amener de l'infiltration
de l'eau de mer à l'intérieur des terres
avec de la saumure qui contamine une
partie des cultures au lieu d'amener
l'inverse donc quand vous êtes à Mayotte
il n'y a quasiment pas
d'agriculture nécessitant une forme
d'irrigation que 85% de la consommation
d'eau de l'île c'est pour l'eau potable
que vous n'avez pas eu de saison des
pluies et que vous avez une population
qui est deux fois plus élevée que ce
pourquoi le réseau a été fait
examinez la possibilité d'aller ouvrir
des usines de dessalement c'est une
question de vie tout court
quand vous êtes en France métropolitaine
à la minute nous parlons ça ressemble à
une fausse bonne idée je dis pas partout
mais je dis que ça ressemble à une
fausse bonne idée et je crois davantage
à des solutions d'innovation technique
j'ai été
invité à aller visiter cette société
Grimaud il y a quelques situés à Grimaux
par des parlementaires de cette maison
et donc je vais considérer que si je si
j'y vais j'aurai l'occasion de vous
joindre cette liste de la même manière
que je veux préciser que le sénateur
chevrolier m'a suggéré qu'on puisse
regarder effectivement comment
réutiliser l'eau des carrières sur
lesquelles il y a parfois des usages qui
mériteraient d'être d'être gardé et et
j'aime cette approche qui consiste à se
demander s'il y a pas des gisements
auxquels nous ne pensons pas ou plus
exactement des lieux ou des méthodes sur
lesquelles il faut qu'on soit capable de
se concentrer même si c'est pas la
solution miracle ça nous fait basculer
dans un mode dans lequel on se demande
comment on économise et l'enjeu il est
crucial et donc si on est capable de
passer d'une logique dans laquelle en
gros
peu importe l'eau c'est infini s'est
renouvelable en nommera jamais à une
logique dans laquelle on se dit quels
sont les alternatives qu'on est capable
de trouver on a déjà gagné une part de
la bataille culturelle dont on a besoin
donc merci pour ces merci pour ces
témoignages et pour ces présentations et
je vous dis cette visite et dans les
tuyaux sont mauvais jeu de mots
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué la sobriété à
propos de l'agriculture notamment mais
elle va concerner également les
particuliers et
aller vers la sobriété c'est déjà bien
connaître sa consommation et on se rend
compte notamment dans les copropriétés
qu'un certain nombre de copropriétés
n'ont pas encore de compteurs
individuels parce que voilà l'assemblée
générale n'y est pas favorable donc
comptez-vous
contraindre dans ce domaine là et
également dans les territoires ruraux
les compteurs sont parfois relevés une
fois par an donc est-ce que vous pensez
là aussi avancer vers de la télérélève
et à quelle échéance donc voilà pour la
première question ensuite vous avez
évoqué le la compétence l'évolution de
la compétence oh c'est à dire de son
transfert obligatoire aux
intercommunalités je vous avoue que
lorsqu'on rencontre les élus il
s'interrogent beaucoup là-dessus sur
voilà vos options que vous envisagez
donc ce que vous pourrez nous en dire un
peu plus
donc j'ai bien entendu vos propos que un
captage unique et risqué parce que il
peut faire l'objet de pollution diffuse
il faudra développer les interconnexions
donc est-ce que l'État va accompagner
les collectivités sur les
interconnexions et par ailleurs sur la
protection des captages je pense quand
même que l'idéal c'est à peu près je
crois 3% des surfaces agricoles que ces
captages soient le moins pollué possible
donc comment pensez-vous on a mon
collègue évoqué les captages
prioritaires il y a eu deux vagues de
500 captages prioritaires sur 35000
c'est bien peu donc comment pensez-vous
là aussi accompagner les
l'agriculture vers une politique
de captage finalement avec un risque de
pollution diffuse très faible voire zéro
je vous remercie
alors
voilà des questions variées sur
lesquelles je vais essayer là aussi de
vous répondre de la manière la plus
précise et la plus sincère qui soit
je commence par la fin
je voulais pas évacuer la question des
captages en disant qu'on aurait de plus
en plus je voulais poser la limite qui
consiste à dire qu'à un moment de toute
façon dans le plan il y avait cette
capacité à doter chaque captage d'un
plan qui nous permet de savoir à quel
moment l'arête et que ce soit pas
aléatoire ou divers en fonction des
secteurs alors je sais bien
d'accompagner des évolutions vers de
l'agriculture biologique ou de
l'agroécologie sur ces points de captage
c'est dans le plan ça fait partie d'un
financement qui est dédié qui représente
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros
complémentaires en moyenne on est déjà
de l'ordre de un peu moins de 10% des
moyens des agences de l'eau 200 millions
d'euros sur le 2 milliards et demi que
nous dépensons qui sont fléchés sur
cette lutte contre les pollutions
agricoles avec des succès mais en fait
on a besoin d'agir de tous les côtés il
faut le garde-fou absolu c'est le pgse
avec le préfet il faut la politique
intermédiaire qui consiste à regarder
comme mon évolue vers des bonnes
pratiques et puis il faut le plan
Écophyto qui fait que de toute façon
avant même de regarder comment on évolue
on a une politique nationale date de
diminution d'une partie d'un tronc dont
on connaît à la fin aujourd'hui une part
de la nocivité et donc c'est bien toute
cette chaîne sur laquelle on avance le
11 juillet
date si j'ai bien compris
pourquoi j'ai ce que j'évoque le 11
juillet
et bien c'est le jour où nous avons
notre comité ego sur le patronage de la
première ministre c'est le jour du vote
du règlement européen
par le Parlement européen en espérant
mais c'est un commentaire personnel qui
ne soit pas à l'image du vote en
commission hier et il se passe un
dernier truc mais ce n'est pas très
grave
bref je sais pas pourquoi je me suis
lancé là-dedans donc pour finir de vous
répondre sur les captages il y a bien
des moyens budgétaires qui accompagnent
à la fois une réflexion nationale et
européenne et un dispositif de suivi
je remonte vos questions
et donc vous m'interrogez sur vers quoi
on va
le droit existant dit 2026 tout le monde
à l'intercommunalité
cette maison
a pointé
le fait que il y avait beaucoup
d'hostilités
en France sur le fait de
d'intercommunaliser la gestion de l'eau
à la minute nous parlons il y a 11000
services gestionnaires d'eau potable en
France 11000
et bien que plus de la moitié des
Français soit d'ores et déjà couverts
par des services intercommunaux
on a une profusion qui engendre deux
types de difficultés
parce qu'il y a une assez forte
corrélation entre risque de rupture
d'eau potable
et taux de fuite
et taille moyenne du service
dans les 700 communes dont je parlais
tout à l'heure privé d'eau potable l'été
dernier c'est 500 qui se retrouvent à
faire de la gestion isolée dans les 170
communes dont nous savons que les taux
de fuite sont supérieurs à 50% c'est 114
qui sont en train gestion isolées
et donc à la fin on ne peut pas faire
comme si on ne s'apercevait pas que
quand on gère l'eau seul forcément une
partie des travaux est plus complexe à
conduire
que l'État aide oui qu'il aide à réparer
les fuites qui les rats financer des
interconnexions bien sûr on met même 180
millions d'euros annuels sur les 475 qui
sont fléchés dans le cadre du plan pour
lutter contre les fuites
mais ça doit se faire
en ayant enfin un minimum de garantie
qu'on sera pas amené à y revenir et je
vais dire les choses avec encore moins
de pudeur
ce sont souvent les endroits où le prix
de l'eau et le moins cher qu'on fait un
arbitrage qui consiste à ne pas faire
les travaux
pour ne pas augmenter le prix
au détriment de la sécurisation de l'eau
potable ou au détriment de la bonne
gestion de la source je ne dis pas que
plus l'eau est chère mieux c'est je
crois pas du tout ça mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que ce n'est pas parce
qu'elle est pas cher que c'est un indice
de bonne gestion à la différence de
d'autres services publics
et il y a des endroits je pense à des
territoires avec des topographies
particulières avec des densités très
faibles et donc avec des longueurs de
tuyaux qui peuvent être très importantes
qui nécessitent un soutien une
solidarité mais à condition qu'on en est
pour notre argent en termes de
sécurisation de l'eau potable
et c'est la question des interconnexions
et en termes de lutte contre les fuites
et là c'est le bon état écologique et
notre intérêt à tous
la PPL sénatoriale est arrivée à
l'Assemblée elle n'a pas permis dans une
journée un peu particulière prévue par
le groupe liotte
d'aller au terme de son examen parce
qu'elle avait été placée en sixième
position dans la niche je me suis
efforcé qu'elle remonte il y avait ce
texte emblématique sur les retraites
mais il y en avait d'autres qui auraient
nécessité qu'elle passe avant parce que
pour nous il y avait deux occasions 1
tenir compte de la position exprimée par
tous les départements de France dans
leur diversité de sécuriser la
possibilité pour les départements de
financer les interconnexions et
d'accompagner les communes nous avons
donné notre accord ces mêmes de mémoire
la mesure 35 sur les 53 du plan qui vous
a été présenté que vous pourrez
retrouver
on a juste pas eu le temps de la faire
voter alors que il y avait un accord
global de tout le monde et le deuxième
c'est de dire interdiction de la gestion
en commun isolé
rétorisons réautorisation entre
guillemets de forme syndicale avec un
système tel qu'il a été voté en
commission parce que j'avoue pour le
coup que je n'ai pas directement
participé à ces discussions c'est
Dominique fort au titre de la compétence
de suivi des élus et qui était votre
interlocutrice sur la PPA l'initiale qui
l'a fait qui consiste en fait à
expliquer que ce serait dans un
processus dans lequel
l'intercommunalisation serait pas remis
en cause la possibilité de rétrocession
immédiate de la compétence commune pour
qu'elle s'organise de manière
infra-intercommunale puisque ça peut
simplifier ce que c'est le bon système
je trouve pas ça une intelligent parce
que ça permet de toucher les deux grands
dispositifs et ça permet d'éviter de Ré
autoriser les syndicats de manière sèche
sans s'efforcer d'avoir une forme de
travail de rationalisation et on touche
l'objectif qu'on poursuivait au début
enfin sur la télé relève
j'aimerais vous remercier parce que
votre questionnaire a effectivement
pointé un sujet dont on parle pas du
tout dans le plan et on sait qu'il y a
une forme de responsabilisation qu'on en
décembre à une échelle individuelle les
chiffres sont très parlants 148 litres
d'eau potable par jour et par personne
un foyer français moyen c'est 120 mètres
cubes mais le chiffre que je trouve le
plus parlant c'est bien celui par
personne et je vous demande d'imaginer
si on débou déposer le matin sur votre
paillasson
les 100 bouteilles d'un litre et demi
correspondant à votre consommation
journalière les 99 et que sur ces
bouteilles il y en a une qui était
marquée pour boire 4 qui étaient marqués
pour préparer la nourriture et que elles
étaient toutes comme ça floquées avec
ceux à quoi elles servent et 20
bouteilles par exemple pour la chasse
d'eau je pense que ça vous ferait
bizarre quand vous voulez rentreriez
dans la maison
et que ça inciterait à mesurer pourquoi
limiter la durée d'une douche faire en
sorte de faire attention à tous les
usages ça évidemment beaucoup de sens
deux choses nous lançons dans les
prochaines heures puisque j'avais dit
que ce serait la fin du mois de juin
l'application plus exactement la
plateforme numérique qui permettra à
chacun de savoir quelle est la situation
en tapant son adresse
d'arrêter de restriction d'alerte qui le
concerne c'est crucial parce que les
restrictions elles arrivent à un moment
ou parfois les gens ne sont pas chez eux
mais eux partent en vacances et où de
bonnes foi ils disent pas à la presse
locale ils se renseigne pas sur savoir
ce qui se passe et je vous rappelle que
la maille n'est pas des départementales
vous pouvez avoir un arrêté préfectoral
qui interdit certains usages sur un
sous-bassin mais qui ne l'interdit pas à
une échelle départementale donc nous
aurons dans les prochaines heures
j'aurai la joie de présenter ce
dispositif
2 et tout est lié ce site rappellera les
bonnes pratiques et on va faire en sorte
qu'ils soient
interconnecté avec l'application de
Météo France
l'enjeu serait qu'à terme quand vous
renseignez sur la température vous
réjouissiez pas seulement qui est du
soleil mais que ça vous permet de savoir
ce qu'est la situation où vous êtes de
l'eau avec une attention particulière à
ces gestes pendant cette période
nous ne pouvons pas mais en tout cas je
n'envisage pas la minute on se parle de
contraindre
les collectivités locales qui sont les
services gestionnaires de l'eau à rendre
obligatoire l'existence de compteur
unique j'en comprends parfaitement
l'intérêt
le dispositif qui consisterait à penser
que c'est à l'état de se substituer à la
responsabilité des collectivités locales
les encourager une bonne pratique ne me
semble pas être une bonne idée mais pour
ne rien vous cacher il y a un moyen qui
pourrait le permettre
quand le président de la République
évoque qui ne serait pas illégitime qui
est une tarification progressive
si quand vous dépassez un certain nombre
de mètres cubes le prix de l'augmente
vous avez intérêt à fractionner en
autant de compteur qu'il y a
d'appartements une propriété collective
pour ne pas vous retrouver avec un prix
moyen de l'eau qui est plus élevé et
c'est donc un système qui serait
responsabilisant qui pousserait entre
guillemets à cette bonne pratique sans
pour autant modifier la règle se
demander de comment on gère la
télérélève j'y suis hyper favorable je
l'ai fait en tant que patron
intercommunalité y compris parce que ça
permet pour l'agglomération que je
connais et pour la communauté urbaine
d'Angers de pouvoir prévenir les gens
quand il y a des niveaux de consommation
anormaux sans attendre la relève et donc
d'avoir une capacité à relever des
fuites en cours de route et d'aider les
gens à éviter d'avoir une facture qui
dérape donc la télé relève elle a aussi
ce mérite en termes de suivi
merci
Louis-Jean de Nicolay merci merci
Monsieur le Ministre moi j'ai deux
questions la première en effet 140
litres d'eau par habitant c'est 35
milliards de mètres cubes d'eau qui
chaque année sont pompés en France pour
l'ensemble des personnes
mais mais quoi
est-ce que sur l'électricité par exemple
sur l'énergie on a vu qu'on avait fait
10 % d'économie sur l'année 2022 je
crois est-ce que vous fixez aussi sur le
lot des pourcentages de de diminution de
consommation globale pour savoir si on
est dans la bonne direction ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point que va
devenir j'ai Mappy j'ai Mappy c'est pour
les inondations dans toutes les parties
de territoire c'est plus près des
inondations aujourd'hui c'est plutôt le
problème de la sécheresse est-ce que
j'ai ma piquer déjà au niveau des
comités de communes en ordre de marche
peut servir à quelque chose en expliquer
que lait était en train de diminuer
alors qu'il fallait en augmenter est-ce
que des retenus des retenus d'eau
peuvent être plus intéressantes que de
les laisser partir vers d'autres vers
d'autres notamment
la mer est-ce qu'il y a une est-ce qu'il
y a un avenir pour cette taxe j'ai ma
pièce cette organisation au niveau des
comité de communes ou c'est quelque
chose de plus qui servira uniquement
pour les inondations et et une taxe
supplémentaire
alors je réalise que et le président
pointe trop et Hervé gilet ont évoqué
effectivement ces questions de
trajectoire et de sobriété et de comment
on allait les renseigner et donc je
merci de reposer la question de comment
est-ce qu'on va faire ces 10%
. on sait pas contenter de fixer un
objectif on a souhaité qu'il puisse être
décliné par bassin parce que quand vous
dites ça vaut pour tout le monde sans
préciser qui ça concerne le risque c'est
que tout le monde se dise que c'est
d'abord à son voisin de faire des
efforts
l'enjeu de cette identification des 4
milliards de mètres cubes par rapport au
33 dont nous souhaitons éviter le
prélèvement on demande à chaque comité
de bassin pour la fin de l'année nous
indiquer les perspectives qui pourraient
utiliser c'est l'augmentation de la part
d'irrigation c'est une mesure spécifique
qui va avoir lieu sur les 50 sites les
plus consommateurs d'eau au niveau
industriel un peu sur le même modèle que
ce qui a été fait pour les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre on prend les plus
visibles et les plus emblématiques parce
que ça entraîne un mouvement et c'est
spectaculaire les économiques vous
pouvez réaliser quand vous mesurez qu'il
faut économiser l'eau et les chiffres
auxquels arrivent des industries qui
réfléchissent à des modèles qui sont
plus économes il y a plein d'exemples je
sais pas du tout ma compétence mais je
dois dire que j'étais très surpris
devant les exemples qui m'ont été
présentés au fur et à mesure du temps et
donc ces trajectoire elles ont vocation
à être présentés pour la fin de l'année
par comité de bassin et c'est ce qui
explique
à la fois l'argent que nous mettons les
délais qui sont donnés et les
perspectives de relèvement et
d'évolution
au milieu de tout ça
[Musique]
plein de questions
y compris certaines que vous avez évoqué
la gestion des inondations n'est pas
moins utile je crains même qu'elle le
soit davantage
puisque quand on dit que le volume d'eau
qui tombera sera le même la
particularité c'est qu'il aura tendance
à se concentrer avec des épisodes qui
seront plus violents et qui pourront
provoquer davantage d'écoulement ou
davantage de difficultés qui
nécessiteront d'être capable
d'intervenir donc aussi contre-intuitif
que ça puisse paraître il nous faut
gérer les sécheresses et les inondations
le dérèglement climatique ça n'est
malheureusement pas quelque chose de
romantique qui consiste à pouvoir se
passer d'un petit pull l'été et à rester
plus longtemps torse nu l'été c'est au
printemps et elle était c'est vraiment
une amplification des phénomènes
extrêmes qui n'ont rien d'agréable que
ce soit les sécheresses que ce soit les
cyclones sur certaines parties de notre
territoire et que ce soit donc ces
épisodes plus vieux extrêmement
importants quand je dis ça
ça pourrait militer à ce moment là pour
qu'on se dise si il tombe plus d'eau à
certains moments pourquoi ne pas la
retenir de manière à pouvoir trouver des
alternatives et une partie de ce que
nous sommes en train de faire
alors
et puis vous avez également évoqué la
question plus large et je vais peut-être
commencer par celle-là de la production
d'électricité en revenant sur les
épisodes que nous connaissons et ça va
être l'occasion pour moi de vous dire
trois choses je vais commencer par ça
2022 a été une année singulière parce
que non seulement on avait ses problèmes
de corrosion sous contrainte dans notre
parc nucléaire
mais on s'est retrouvé en plus à cause
de la sécheresse avec un niveau de
production hydroélectrique qui a
pénalisé notre mix énergétique
globalement
ce qui est vrai hier les aujourd'hui à
la minute où nous parlons 68% de nona
phréatiques en dessous des normes de
saison
la sécheresse hivernale que nous avons
connue
est venu accentuer les difficultés qu'on
avait eu l'été dernier on a eu la chance
d'avoir de la pluie globalement en avril
en mai et une partie du mois de juin de
manière très inégalement répartie et qui
a moins rempli les nappes puisqu'elle
est arrivée dans un contexte où les
températures étaient plus élevées ou la
végétation avait davantage besoin comme
j'ai eu l'occasion de vous le dire
néanmoins on a une situation aujourd'hui
qui est plutôt bonne en particulier en
Bretagne et pas mauvaise sur une large
partie des Pays de la Loire
qui est très inquiétante sur le pourtour
méditerranéen sur la vallée du Rhône qui
concentre une partie de nos capacités
hydroélectriques
et qui contenu de la sécheresse Express
que nous avons vécu dans une partie du
Nord et de l'Est
conduit à ce que les choses soient pas
totalement derrière nous et à ce qu'on
soit extrêmement vigilant
et donc dans ce contexte cette question
d'hydroélectricité elle est évidemment
elle est cruciale et j'attire votre
attention sur le rapport de la Cour des
comptes qui a été remis au Sénat
sur le coup de l'adaptation au
changement climatique des centrales
nucléaires en particulier sur la partie
haut et sur les évolutions éventuelles
entre les circuits ouverts et les
circuits fermés qui permettraient de
moins dépendre pour des productions
électriques du niveau moyen des
températures avec les histoires
habituelles de rejet
la question de l'hydroélectricité un
jour pourra aussi amener à se pencher
sur des projets qui doivent sans doute
être revus à l'aune de ce que nous
connaissons
je pense à l'étang de Berre où on a une
pollution à l'eau douce vous avez bien
entendu qui a conduit
le juge a demandé à EDF de diminuer sa
production d'hydroélectricité pour
limiter le relâchement d'eau douce dans
un étang d'eau salée
lire ça aujourd'hui même si je conteste
pas la réalité de la pollution à l'eau
douce
en mesurant qu'il y a quelques années
seulement 5 ou 6 l'idée c'était de se
demander comment l'eau douce
issue du circuit hydroélectricité on
pouvait plus vite la jeter dans la mer
alors qu'on n'est pas loin de la plaine
du Cros avec des enjeux énormes pour la
Camargue en termes de production
agricole voire même pourra imaginer un
système dans lequel on remonte cette eau
pour qu'elle refasse tourner une
deuxième fois une partie de nos
centrales hydroélectriques pour
reprendre
l'exemple de jean-bapti bon bref on voit
le champ des possibles et des domaines
dans lesquels il faut qu'on soit capable
de travailler j'arrive aux retenus je
veux pas perdre le fil on a environ 15
milliards de mètres cubes de retenue
dans ce pays
sous plein de formes le débat autour de
quelques grands projets très limités
doivent faire oublier d'abord toutes les
retenues multi-usages la vérité c'est
que dès qu'on a en même temps un usage
agricole un usage touristique un usage à
des fins de faune et de flore et de
biodiversité le niveau des polémiques
n'est pas le même il faut aussi
reconnaître que une vieille retenue est
une bonne retenue et qu'une retenue
récente elle suscite
davantage d'émotions il n'y a pas de
meilleur retenu que les lymphatique les
retenues ne nous dispensent pas de nous
poser la question de la sobriété parce
qu'à la fin il y aura pas de solution
miracle qui fait qu'on pourra poursuivre
comme avant
et l'Espagne doit quand même nous
alerter ils ont misé à fond sur les
retenues après avoir misé sur les
retenues ils ont pompé dans les nappes
et pas seulement dans les herbes de
surface mais même dans des nappes
quaternaires et je pense qu'il y aura
des lendemains qui des chantent compte
tenu du fait qu'ils ont en plus
multiplié des productions de maraîchage
qui sont extrêmement consommatrices en
nous donc tout est lié
mon niveau de consommation en eau
tenir compte des solides etc comment on
fait pour répondre du coup à la question
que vous me posez
je ne pense pas qu'il y a une réponse
nationale satisfaisante je pense qu'elle
est réponses elles sont à regarder
territoire par territoire avec la pluie
des scientifiques et j'assume de dire
que quand j'ai un sous-sol car stick
c'est à dire des nappes phréatiques qui
ne retiennent pas l'eau mais qui sont
fuyantes pomper dans une nappe fuyante
c'est comme pompée dans de l'eau qui ne
reste pas qui va plus vite à la mer si
je pompe de l'eau qui va à la mer on
peut discuter si je pompe de l'eau qui
est censé être dans une nappe et donc
protéger de l'évaporation et de
l'évapo-transpiration par le sol ça
n'aurait pas de sens de la mettre en
surface donc il faut qu'on tienne compte
de ça les quatre degrés à la fin de ce
siècle et la réalité de ce qui est déjà
le changement climatique avec une hausse
moyenne de 1,7 degrés par rapport à
l'air pré-industriel que nous
connaissons
nous conduisent à faire évoluer les
modèles en gros jusqu'à maintenant c'est
explore 2070 qui est le nom de code du
programme de simulation qui nous permet
sur la base des anticipations
en termes de température de déterminer
vers quoi on va
en annonçant les 4 degrés en parallèle
nous sommes en train de travailler sur
explore 2
qui je pense sera disponible environ
dans un an et qui permettra d'aller
modéliser avec des évolutions de
température plus élevées que celles que
nous connaissons de refaire tourner si
j'ose dire les modèles dont nous parlons
pour une partie des projets parce qu'une
partie de la polémique qui a eu lieu
dans les Deux-Sèvres elle a été de dire
oui mais les données sont pas
actualisées ce sont les seules données
scientifiques qu'on connaît c'est par
définition elles ont été établies entre
2006 et 2011 sur des projections qui
étaient celles de l'époque sur
l'évolution des températures donc nous
faisons évoluer le modèle
mais on peut pas nous reprocher de ne
pas faire des prévisions au doigt
mouillé ou en écoutant ce qui sont
militants mais d'essayer de construire
un outil qui s'appuie sur la somme de ce
qui est disponible en terme de
compétences et ce sera le juge de paix
parce que globalement il y a des
endroits où c'est justifié il y en a où
ça ne l'est pas et ce qu'on est sur du
colinéaire même le colinéaire n'est pas
forcément justifié dire que vous retenez
de l'autre pluie ça dépend où elle va si
elle alimente c'est évidemment ça heurte
moins l'esprit que d'imaginer des
dispositifs de pompage mais il faut pas
parer les vertus de tous les les
bassines ou les retenues de tous les
mots mais il faut pas non plus les
parler de toutes les vertus on est
vraiment
sur des choses qui sont à regarder en
fonction de la réalité des sols et des
besoins et qui ne dispensent pas des
autres efforts et trajectoires de
sobriété
merci Monsieur Sylviane et ensuite
Sylvie Robert
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre j'aurais souhaité rebondir
sur la question des barrages
hydroélectriques et notamment sur la
mise en concurrence voulue par les
instants européennes vous le savez ils
n'ont pas qu'une vocation de production
d'énergie mais il joue également un
grand rôle dans le soutien litierge
l'agriculture la pêche les sports en eau
vivent les refroidissements des des
centrales et cette mise en concurrence à
venir préoccupe grandement les élus de
la montagne qui redoutent un
morcellement du marché et une moindre
efficience des missions données à ces à
l'ensemble de ces barrages
hydroélectriques dont l'exploitation est
aujourd'hui assuré à 80% par EDF on sait
que certains de nos partenaires
européens ont réussi à s'exonérer de
cette réglementation j'aurais souhaité
connaître la vie de la France je vous
remercie
sur le fait qu'il s'agit quand même d'un
sujet qui relève davantage de la
transition énergétique puisque c'est la
question directe de la production
d'électricité il vous a pas échappé
qu'évidemment depuis 2015
remarque précontentieux procédure 2019
etc
et le projet Hercule qui a tant fait
parler de lui et qui consiste à regarder
s'il y avait pas matière à faire évoluer
une partie du statut d'EDF il visait
pour partir à répondre à ses critiques
en imaginant qu'on pourrait isoler dans
une quasi régie les activités
d'hydroélectricité d'EDF de manière à
respecter l'esprit et surtout la lettre
du droit européen
ce que je peux dire
à ce sujet parce que finalement depuis
2022 le sujet n'apparaît réellement
bouger la position de la France elle est
simple il faut qu'on continue à miser
sur notre hydroélectricité on est
attaché à notre modèle et nous préparons
le plan qui nous permet si Bruxelles
doit continuer à durcir ses positions de
montrer que nous y répondrons sans
partir sur des ouvertures à la
concurrence qui nous semble
hasardeuses contenu des niveaux
d'investissement c'est difficile d'être
plus précis à ce stade et je précise
pour ceux qui auraient eu
l'attention nécessaire
au moment des questions au gouvernement
de dire que quand j'ai fait cette
réponse sur la vie du Conseil d'État
concernant les sociétés d'autoroute à
Olivier Jacquin il y a environ
une heure et demie de cela
quand le Conseil d'État dit que une
imposition pour les sociétés d'autoroute
devrait conduire
à ce que toutes les concessions
délivrées par l'État soient considérés
comme une catégorie homogène il y a en
fait trois catégories de concessions par
l'État
il y a les autoroutes qui représentent
les trois quarts la fois du chiffre de
la valeur etc
il y a les aéroports du moindre mesure
et il y a l'hydroélectricité
même si Robert merci monsieur le
Président moi je vais revenir sur la
réponse que vous avez faite à notre
collègue Florence matrix compta sur la
question de la tarification progressive
au social et les compteurs
individualisés dans les copropriétés
vous avez répondu finalement c'est au
regard de pratique plus vertueuses que
il s'apercevront que ce sera peut-être
plus utile et plus efficace d'installer
ces compteurs
je suis à moitié satisfaite de la
réponse pour être dans un territoire qui
applique cette tarification depuis de
longues années je peux vous dire que les
résistances sont encore fortes et que
l'installation dans les copropriétés
sont difficiles
pour des questions de moyens pour des
questions voilà qui relèvent aussi
de pratique qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
ne sont pas en tout cas légion est-ce
que vous iriez quand même jusqu'à
pouvoir contraindre
par la loi à ce que
on puisse installer des compteurs
individuels dans des copropriétés je
suis à Rennes Métropole on fait depuis
très longtemps je peux vous dire qu'il y
a je le dis parce qu'il y a une
sensibilisation inaccuration de tous les
acteurs à cette question là et je dois
mais ça évolue très très lentement
malgré toute la prise de conscience que
l'on a des questions quand l'identité
qualité vous voyez c'est pas si évident
que ça donc je revenais un peu pour
savoir si on pouvait aller plus loin ou
en tout cas ce que vous en pensez c'est
tout alors voilà merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre je vais commencer par une
confidence j'ai ce week-end pas pour me
détendre mais parce que je pense que le
local est national sont loués sont liées
comparé un certain nombre de politiques
d'eau de collectivités territoriales
pour puiser des idées pour ma propre
collectivité j'ai été marqué parce que
vous faites à Rennes en termes de
soutien
à l'installation de récupérateur d'eau
de pluie et c'est un exemple parmi
d'autres il y a Dunkerque qui se
positionne également de manière efficace
mais avec des vrais politiques de
soutien et pourquoi je vous dis ça parce
que j'ai demandé à mes services pardon
au service de la collectivité dont je
suis un simple membre mais j'ai gardé
quelques amis
d'avant mon accession au gouvernement de
regarder comment pousser des mesures que
je crois
utile pour les gestionnaires de ces
réseaux
et ce qui fait le plus économiser de
l'eau c'est pas le compteur individuel
c'est des kits par exemple de mousseur
c'est les économiseurs
je dis ça juste pour objectiver le débat
et pour que vous sachiez que on peut se
concentrer sur les compteurs mais en
vrai ce qu'on souhaite c'est pas que la
facture soit mieux répartie c'est qu'on
consomme le moins possible et donc pour
consommer le moins possible
sauf celui qui parce qu'il paye trop
cher déciderait de baisser sa
consommation mais les gens sont rares en
fait on est dépendant d'une durée
psychologique d'eau qui coule pour
mouiller sa brosse à dents se laver les
mains faire un certain de choses et dans
beaucoup de cas
ça n'est pas la quantité d'eau qui
compte pour nous c'est le temps pendant
lequel le robinet coule donc dans les
évolutions des gestes là on a un
gisement objectif sur lequel on peut
avancer
premier sujet deuxièmement la question
des compteurs en fait elle a été
longuement évoquée dans la préparation
du plan et à la fin pour la raison que
je viens de vous décrire le Comité
national de l'eau
a émis un avis défavorable à son
inclusion dans le plan en disant quoi
en disant
c'est de la responsabilité des
collectivités locales et donc si on est
attaché à la libre administration
jusqu'où on doit aller dans la précision
du service
tout s'entend je vous exprime parce que
les 53 mesures
je le redis on aurait pu en faire
davantage on aurait pu en faire moins je
dis pas qu'il faudra pas revenir sur
certaines à ce stade on a considéré
qu'il fallait faire confiance et que la
bataille prioritaire c'était pas celle
sur l'individualisation des compteurs
c'est celle sur la diminution de la
consommation et donc plutôt regarder sur
les kits et des dispositifs de ce type
sur lequel il pourrait y avoir d'autres
initiatives de prise plus tard voilà
pour faire simple là où nous en sommes
je veux pas faire semblant de vous dire
que je suis en totale désaccord avec
vous ce serait faux mais je peux pas non
plus des juger pour être clair un
consensus qui aboutit à ce qu'on
considère que ça n'était pas dans les
priorités et tant mieux si on a des
collectivités locales qui vont plus loin
et on donne le moyen d'aller plus loin
si vous dites que le 121ème mètre cube
coûte plus cher que le 119e
par définition vous avez intérêt avoir
autant de compteurs qui a d'appartements
puisque c'est 120 en moyenne par foyer
et vous remplissez plusieurs objectifs
dans le même coup faire davantage
contribuer ceux qui ont déjà cousu ou
des piscines ou qui font moins attention
à leur consommation et pousser à une
individualisation
merci Monsieur mélisse alors Christina
Pluchet merci c'est présent monsieur le
ministre oui peut-être une intervention
pour garder quand même un point de
vigilance
sur l'agriculture parce qu'effectivement
depuis un certain temps on fait porter
sur le monde agricole tous les mots de
la planète
et récemment encore avec ce magnifique
rapport de la Cour des comptes donc je
pense qu'effectivement on a
on a quand même un certain nombre de
rapports depuis un certain temps oui qui
sont toujours très à charge envers
envers notre modèle agricole alors même
que je pense et je suis même presque sûr
qu'il est dans des plus propres au monde
donc
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il faut
maintenant être prudent on a quand même
un monde agricole qui est un petit peu
fatigué par tout ça qui a été très
fragilisé ces dernières années par le
changement climatique parler du
réchauffement changement climatique oui
c'est un phénomène qui date pas 2022 qui
date plutôt même depuis 2015
on a quand même effectivement des
phénomènes
des excès on va dire on a récurrent
récurrent qui des excès qui dont
on avait l'habitude de voir tous les 10
ans qui sont maintenant à peu près enfin
qui qu'on a qu'on a tous les ans ou tous
les deux ans en fait effectivement ça
c'est une certitude cela étant dit
effectivement il faut pas taper sur les
gens qui nourrissent on a besoin de nos
agriculteurs et je pense que maintenant
il faut arrêter les restrictions sans
compensation on a eu les ADN t il y a
quelques temps là on parle des zones de
captage même pour effectivement les
agriculteurs biologiques et qui sont en
bio il y a il y a un certain nombre de
restrictions qui sont difficiles
facilement soutenables voilà donc je
tiens effectivement à vous alerter
là-dessus le monde agricole est fatigué
par tout ça on lui fait peser tous les
mots de la planète et alors même ce sont
des gens qui s'investissent énormément 7
jours sur 7 pour nous nourrir voilà
vous savez la sénatrice dans ma vie j'ai
eu la grande chance de siéger pendant un
peu moins de deux ans la commission
agricole du Parlement européen
avec Monsieur Le Foll monsieur Beauvais
et Monsieur Dantin
j'ai été le président d'un département
qui est le deuxième pour le
renouvellement des jeunes actifs et qui
abrité jusqu'à peu de temps à une
quarantaine de kilomètres de l'endroit
où j'habite une femme qui était
présidente du premier syndicat agricole
de ce pays donc
il m'arrive assez souvent d'être
ambiancé par ce monde agricole la fois
sur la réalité sur son épuisement et sur
un certain nombre de sujets
moi je peux vous assurer d'une constance
et d'une grande cohérence
une partie de nos politiques écologique
elle repose sur une hypocrisie qui
consiste à durcir les règles ici mais à
continuer à faire venir des produits
qu'on importe avec ou des conséquences
en termes de réglementation
environnementale ou des conséquences en
termes d'émission qu'on accepterait pas
chez nous
et donc le sujet ce sont les clauses
miroirs et ce qui est vrai demain
globalement sur les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre il faut qu'on le
systématise dans d'autres domaines si on
ne le fait pas si on règlement de la
taille de nos élevages en considérant
qu'on a un sujet de bien-être animal
au-delà que ça a des conséquences mais
qu'on laisse de la viande arriver du
bout du monde sans impliquer les mêmes
règles avec l'accélération de la
déforestation dans certaines parties du
monde qui non ce qui aggravent en plus
la difficulté et en se privant des
recettes économiques qui sont liées à
des activités qui nous permettent
d'aller financer une transition qui soit
solidaire et juste mais pour lequel il
faut d'abord gagner de l'argent avant
d'être capable de le dépenser on aura un
sujet
c'est vrai dans plein de domaines
ça dépend la gestion de la forêt pour la
sylviculture au sens large sur
lesquelles quand on ouvre les yeux et
quand on regarde des choses ont été
dites effectivement sur les besoins mais
on sait qu'on a aussi un besoin de
captage de carbone et de stockage dans
les sols d'une partie de ce qui permet
de faire le reste ça l'est pour les
productions agricoles quand il s'agit de
se nourrir et quand on voit le nombre de
domaines dans lequel nous sommes un
porteurs je peux vous assurer qu'on n'a
pas fait un plan dont l'objectif serait
de se demander comment alimenter la
baisse de l'agriculture et je vais
terminer sur un point
tout lien avec un rapport récent de la
Cour des comptes étant évidemment
fortuit
l'eau incite quand même à se poser la
question de savoir si tous nos espaces
agricoles doivent être cultivés et à
quel point l'élevage n'est pas aussi un
moyen d'aller rendre service à ce cycle
de l'eau en faisant en sorte qu'on ait
des endroits qui stockent et qui
nécessitent pas une irrigation Haddock
parce que si je remplace une prairie par
une terrible et ou cultivée mon besoin
n'est pas le même et donc il faut aussi
qu'on soit capable d'intégrer tout ça je
vais pas faire un truc avec une table de
3 en 2 minutes je dis juste que encore
une fois
l'agriculture c'est une partie des
solutions dont on a besoin pour être
capable de boucler tout ça
merci moi j'ai deux ou trois questions
à vous poser une première sur le
problème de financement notamment des
agences de bassin
moi quand on nous a dit que le FB allait
être géré par les agences de l'eau afin
d'intégrer
j'avais je m'étais un petit peu
mis en colère mais ça m'avait quand même
soulevé quelques émotions sur le
financement parce que l'Agence de l'eau
avec déjà le plafond mordant à certains
nombre de difficultés pour financer un
certain nombre d'opérations dont les
canalisations fuyantes est-ce que vous
pensez que on pourrait pas trouver une
solution pour que le FB puisse trouver
d'autres financements extérieurs à leurs
agences de bassin ça c'est ma première
question la deuxième c'est sur un une
expérience que j'ai vécu la semaine
dernière sur mon territoire dans mon
canton où on a vécu un accident
climatique
qu'on n'avait jamais vu et que j'ai
crainte qu'on le retrouve régulièrement
on a eu ça à peu près 100 mm d'eau en
une heure
avec de la grêle
et une tornade type comme on voit
maintenant aux États-Unis moi j'avais
jamais vu ça qui a emporté tout un
village et une partie de forêt et on a à
peu près on a fait le calcul avec la
chambre de la culture on a reçu un
million de mètres cubes d'eau
en
une heure donc c'est toute cette eau
elle a elle a peu pénétrer et elle est
partie directement dans la dans la
rivière dans les dans les ruisseaux et
elle est partie à la mer directement
comment avec une partie du limon bon
plus 60 hectares qui ont grarélé de
vignes qui il y a plus rien enfin
c'était assez
c'est vraiment un cataclysme qu'on n'a
jamais vu chez nous est-ce que vous
pensez pas qu'à un moment donné il faut
qu'on s'adapte bien sûr à ces épisodes
qu'on va retrouver
est-ce que vous pensez pas que ça serait
intéressant d'étudier la mise en place
de bassin d'orage multi-usage qui
permettrait à la fois de
pour l'eau
des services de la ville pour les
services incendies pour
éventuellement d'irrigation parce qu'on
va retrouver à mon avis ce genre de
phénomène régulièrement et c'est de
l'eau qu'on pourrait capter en quelques
en quelques heures
est-ce que c'est une solution et puis
dernier point
moi je voudrais savoir quel était le
point ou qu'elles étaient les les sujets
que dans les
qu'on a oublié les 53 mesures parce
qu'on a comme on va déposer notre
rapport le 11 juillet
on pourrait très bien imaginer de de
s'inspirer de deux ou trois sujets que
vous avez pu oublier dans vos 53 mesures
que nous on a peut-être pensé parce que
il y a certains de sujets qu'on va il y
en aura des nouveaux sujets mais est-ce
que vous avez des sujets que vous allez
aimer
évoqué dans les 53 mesures qui ont été
oubliées
merci président et au-delà de vos
questions merci pour cette invitation
pour la possibilité que j'ai eu de
pouvoir répondre aux questions de votre
mission d'information
je ne sais pas pour les bassins de rage
je vais étonné avec vous ce qui me
perturbe c'est il faut qu'il soit mis au
bon endroit le
territoire sur lequel ça tombe
voilà donc
j'entends je pense que ça fait partie
aujourd'hui des questions pour
lesquelles on a aussi besoin de réponse
et de continuer à modéliser une partie
de ses aimants je trouve comme ça l'idée
plutôt intelligente je le dis
quelle dimensionnement quelles
conséquences qu'elles font est-ce que si
on les bâche ça n'a pas aussi quelques
incidences sur la perméabilité bref et
du coup et du coup quelle règle aussi de
relâchement éventuel si ils sont remplis
à certains bref
je pense que c'est un sujet qui mérite
d'être creusé
pour le spécialiste que vous êtes
monsieur le Président je comprends que
le financement de l'ofb vous avez heurté
à vrai dire sur une question principe
parce qu'avant on avait tendance à dire
que l'eau paye l'eau
et des phrases simples
qui permettent de s'inscrire dans un bon
sens paysan pas seulement du cher mais
de toute notre pays ça évidemment
beaucoup de sens
mais l'idée qu'une partie des ressources
de l'Office français de la biodiversité
s'appuie sur l'eau
même si elle heurte ce principe et cette
maxime elle dit quelque chose de vrai
c'est qu'on a besoin pour notre
biodiversité d'avoir une relation
étroite entre les agences et l'office
français c'est lui qui est chargé de
vérifier le respect des arrêtés qui sont
pris sur la base de ce qui se passe
c'est lui qui fait en sorte de s'assurer
du bon écoulement et du bon suivi et
donc je vous ferai une réponse qui est
pas une réponse de Normand mais qui
consiste à dire il y a un état du droit
que je n'ai pas remis en cause les
nouveaux financements ne s'appuient pas
là dessus n'augmente pas les moyens de
l'ofb et la stratégie nationale de
biodiversité qui vous sera présentée
avant la fin de l'année qui devra se
traduire par des compléments de
financement ne puisera pas ses
financements dans des agences de l'eau
on va pas faire du Shadok on n'est pas
en train de dire on ajoute des crédits
mais on vous ajoutera des obligations
là que les choses soient extrêmement
claires
enfin qu'est-ce qui manque
si j'avais eu la réponse à cette
question le 29 mars j'aurais fait en
sorte qu'il ne manque rien le 30 membre
de la présentation avec quelques
semaines de recul
on a peu parlé d'assainissement
et les choses sont liées
voilà la seule réponse que je
que je consentirais je pense que vous
serez capable d'en faire votre miel
peut-être y compris sur la question des
eaux pluviales en pouvant qu'on peut
aller plus loin ce que je souhaite je
peux formuler un souhait mais ça ne sera
qu'un souhait il sera procès-verbal si
vous le souhaitez
il arrive parfois que
la qualité des comptes rendus des
missions du Sénat conduisent
à susciter des
polémiques et des prises de conscience
je pense que si peu de temps après la
présentation du plan nous avons besoin
de quelques encouragements de ceux qui
font preuve de sagesse et qu'on pointe
les axes d'amélioration mais que la
quasi-totalité des acteurs qui ont
travaillé en tant masqué sur ce plan
puis c'est aussi encouragé dans ce qui
est
un vrai travail collectif je le redis la
fierté des agences la fierté des de ceux
qui sont en première ligne elle est ce
qui m'importe de regarder comment on le
fait vivre tout l'enjeu pour moi entre
maintenant et la fin de l'année jusqu'au
PLF
c'est que toutes ces actions on les
fasse entrer dans l'atmosphère et que
les engagements qui ont été salués ils
soient suivi des actes il est arrivé par
le passé qui est des plans
qui soit célébrés au moment de leur
lancement et qui quand on se retournait
avait fait l'objet d'un taux de
réalisation de suivi qui soit pas
totalement à la hauteur de ce qui avait
été annoncé donc si votre rapport
suggère ou décidait qui sera souhaitable
de manière régulière de regarder où nous
en sommes sur le suivi des engagements
ce serait aussi une manière de faire
oeuvre utile au lieu d'indiquer ce que
pourrait être les engagements
complémentaires le 54 la 55 la 56e
mesure qui pourrait être mise en œuvre
un immense merci en tout cas pour
que complément de questions ce sera très
rapide pour respecter votre cadre en
termes de temps une question peut-être
simplement qui nous apparaît comme
importante notamment au travers des
rencontres de terrain notamment dans les
Deux-Sèvres par rapport à Sainte Soline
ou objectivement quand on a rencontré
l'ensemble des acteurs nous avons été
marqués par
la détresse
la dureté
par rapport à la situation qui a été
vécue vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des
parties prenantes l'ensemble des parties
prenantes et on sait clairement aperçu
que dans cette situation même en
relation avec les services de l'État ce
ministre
il y avait quelque part une situation
qui était bloquée et qui interrogeait
sur la capacité à en sortir
et c'est un sujet de fond en fait qu'on
voit maintenant émerger sur d'autres
d'autres sujets donc on voit bien que
sur cette situation là il faudrait
aujourd'hui une capacité de médiation
qui neutraliserait les positions pour
réessayer et tenter de remettre un
certain nombre d'acteurs autour de la
table donc là il y a une question de
fond qui se pose et objectivement nous
ne pensons pas que les acteurs en
présence à l'heure actuelle sont
capacité de le faire tout seul
sincèrement ce qui amène à un sujet plus
large qui peut être intéressant on a
évoqué un moment donné sur les Draux les
concessions d'hydroélectricité la creux
mais dans certains pays il existe aussi
une autorité de régulation sur l'eau qui
comprend qu'il y a aussi la compétence
haut et compte tenu de la montée des
enjeux aujourd'hui sur ces sujets là
c'est un sujet qui mériterait une
attention
peut-être dans l'immédiat mais qui est
un chantier qui soit ouvert sur ce sujet
là parce que il y a des questions de qui
sont posées et ça renvoie ensuite à la
qualification des médiations et de la
médiation que nous pourrions mettre
aussi en place dans notre pays où il
existe aussi par ailleurs des garants de
l'eau dans d'autres dans certains pays
et cette notion-là elle est aussi
intéressante dans la capacité de mettre
en place des médiations locales et
territoriales qu'en pensez-vous
on a inventé un modèle
qui repose quand même sur des parlements
de l'eau où on a tous les usagers
globalement nos agences nos comités de
bassins quand on les compare et quand on
regarde ce qu'on a été capable de
traverser depuis des décennies il faut
être capable de leur rendre hommage
je le dis parce que quand on objective
et qu'en garde et avec une idée
c'est que la même règle à pas forcément
vocation à s'appliquer partout ce qui
dans un pays comme le nôtre et vous êtes
bien précis pour le savoir n'est quand
même pas l'évidence si on avait sur un
mouvement inverse celui consiste à se
dire
il faut faire preuve de davantage de
centralisation dans le suivi c'est ma
petite inquiétude si on allait vers une
croc sur le modèle de la crue parce
qu'il y a une différence énorme
nous sommes interconnectés au niveau
énergétique
si notre capacité de demande dépasse
notre niveau de production le blackout
il est généralisé et pour tout le monde
l'eau on peut avoir un territoire qui
n'en a plus depuis deux mois et c'est le
cas en France et des territoires qui
n'en manqueront pas de toute l'année
donc cette idée d'aller créer une forme
d'interdépendance entre nous qui
susciterait le sentiment qu'on met en
place un monstre administratif là où il
y en a pas besoin je suis pas sûr que ce
soit ce dont on a besoin dans le domaine
on a besoin de règles qui moralise et
qui permettent de montrer qu'il y a une
forme d'éthique mais tenir compte de la
disponibilité qui a depuis toujours
orienter une partie des usages
touristiques agricoles de mon point de
vue ça a du sens
sur Sainte Soline
je rencontre Thierry Burlot dans
quelques jours
il me semble qu'il a partagé avec vous
certaines pistes j'irai pas plus loin si
vous voulez bien il me semble
que c'était prévu vendredi que j'ai été
contraint de le décaler au début de la
semaine prochaine
j'entends vos remarques comme j'ai
entendu celle du terrain il y a quelques
semaines il y avait un temps
aussi pendant lequel
par rapport à ce qui avait été blessé
dans leur chair des deux côtés donner
sentiment que il fallait se précipiter
de tout réinterroger sans doute pas été
le plus judicieux on rentre dans un
temps avec l'été qui est plus propice au
fait de s'apaiser de se demander ce qui
est souhaitable pour l'avenir de
regarder en face les évolutions et c'est
ce que nous allons faire
très bien écoutez je pense qu'on a fait
un bon tour d'horizon de tous les sujets
merci d'avoir répondu à chacun et on va
maintenant terminer ce rapport et on
vous le présentera au plus vite le 11
juillet au soir il sera à votre
disposition merci encore